inciso b determina la coordenada x del
punto en el que g tiene un máximo
absoluto en el intervalo menos 4 menor o
igual que x menor igual que 3 justifica
tu respuesta ok
antes de empezar a resolver este inciso
como tal quiero hablarles de términos
generales supongamos que yo tengo una
función cualquiera así que voy a dibujar
un plano cartesiano y recuerden que esta
función es una función cualquiera no es
mi función g de cuya derivadas esta
gráfica que tenemos a la derecha
entonces supongamos que este plano
cartesiano y este verde va a ser mi
intervalo en el cual quiero buscar el
máximo absoluto de mi función entonces
qué casos tengo mi primer caso va a ser
que mi función sea de este estilo es
decir que el máximo absoluto se
encuentre al inicio del intervalo donde
está definida mi función mi segundo
posible caso va a ser que mi función sea
de este estilo es decir que en un máximo
absoluto se encuentra al final del
intervalo donde está definida mi función
y mi tercer y último caso va a ser que
mi función sea de este estilo
así bien es decir que mi máximo absoluto
esté en un punto crítico de mi función
definida en ese intervalo aunque estoy
diciendo un punto crítico entre comillas
porque no forzosamente la derivada tiene
que ser cero podríamos tener una función
de este estilo algo parecido a esto una
función picuda en cuyo caso no es
diferenciable sin embargo el máximo
absoluto se encuentra en este punto y
entonces ya tenemos el menú para el
inciso b que estamos viendo en este
vídeo lo primero que vamos a hacer es
ver el valor de g en sus puntos extremos
es decir en su punto inicial y en su
punto final y después vamos a ver si
tiene un punto crítico distinto a estos
puntos extremos y encontrar el valor de
g en ese punto crítico así que empecemos
de una vez con este ejercicio lo primero
que voy a hacer entonces es evaluar que
en sus puntos extremos primero voy a
empezar con el punto inicial con x igual
a menos 4 entonces quienes queden menos
4 pues vamos a sustituir en g 2 x menos
más la integral de 0 a menos 4 de ft dt
recuerden cada vez que yo veo a x pongo
menos cuatro y todos x menos 4 pues es
muy sencillo es menos 8 mejor lo voy a
borrar y lo voy a poner de corrido para
ahorrar lo más que se pueda despacio
menos 8 más y quién es esta integral de
0 a menos cuatro df de tdt esto lo vimos
en el primer inciso en el vídeo pasado
recuerden que cuando tenemos los índices
de integración volteados es decir en la
parte de arriba el índice de integración
pequeño y en la parte de abajo y de
integración mayor entonces para corregir
este error lo que hay que hacer es poner
un signo de menos esto es lo mismo que
menos la integral de menos cuatro a cero
de efe de t
dt y así va a ser mucho más fácil
resolver esta integral
pero bueno quién es esta integral que
tenemos aquí esta integral es el área
que hay entre el eje de las x en curva
efe
entonces dese cuenta que esta área se
divide en dos en un círculo pequeño en
un cuarto en un círculo pequeño y un
cuarto de un círculo grande sin embargo
la primera área la área del círculo
pequeño es una área negativa porque
porque está bajo d
de las x mientras que la segunda área es
un área positiva por lo tanto lo que voy
a hacer es tomar el área de positiva ya
esta área restarle el área negativa bien
pero esta área de menos 3 a 0 ya le
habíamos sacado en el primer inciso en
el vídeo anterior esta área correspondía
a un cuarto de un círculo de radio 3
pero ten en cuenta que son dos cuartos
de círculo un círculo cuyo radio estrés
este círculo grande entonces voy a poner
un cuarto que multiplica a un círculo
cuyo radio es 3 cuál es el área de un
círculo cuyos radios 3 pues es 9 porque
el área spears por radio al cuadrado o
sea por 3 al cuadrado 9 bien y ahora hay
que quitarle el área negativa pero la
negativa es un círculo mucho más pequeño
no voy a dibujar aquí es este círculo
que tengo aquí cuyo radio es 1 cuál es
el área de un círculo cuyo radio es 1
pues va a ser pi por radio al cuadrado o
sea y por 1 al cuadrado o sea p entonces
hay que quitarle pi y recuerdan que este
un cuarto de afuera es x
solamente tenemos un cuarto de círculos
de cada uno de los dos ahora sí nueve
pies ocho y ocho por un cuarto pues es
dos pi
entonces esto se puede simplificar un
cuarto por nueve menos pi es lo mismo
que un cuarto por ocho piqué es lo mismo
que dos p entonces todo esto lo voy a
cancelar para poner 2 espn y ahora sí
que tengo pues que de menos 4 va a ser
igual a menos 8 menos 2 para que de
hecho quien sabe que el número sea este
es como menos 14 punto y algo no lo sé
pero el chiste es que es negativo es un
punto negativo bueno ahora vamos a ver
qué pasa en el otro extremo de mi
función en mi parte final de mi función
y como el intervalo está definido de
menos 43 voy a tomar g de 3 y quién es
que de tres jueces dos por tres más la
integral de cero a tres de efe de t de t
esto es por la definición de g y ahora
sí dos por tres es 6 y la integral de 03
df de tdt pues es esta área
- esta área de acá sin embargo si se dan
cuenta estas dos áreas se anulan porque
esta área es positiva y esta área es
negativa y es la misma área están
delimitadas por el eje de las equis y
como corta esta recta en 1.5 estas dos
áreas son iguales por lo tanto todo esto
es cero
entonces g de 3 es simple y
sencillamente 6 lo que nos da también
una idea de que deje de menos 4 ya no
nos sirve porque era un número negativo
y ya encontramos un valor mayor a este
número negativo que teníamos si 6 es
mucho más grande que menos 8 menos 2 p
por lo tanto que de menos 4 ya no es
candidato para ser el máximo absoluto en
ese intervalo sin embargo no hemos
acabado ya nos falta la última parte que
es calcular si que tiene puntos críticos
y ver cuánto vale que en esos puntos
críticos para sacar dos puntos críticos
primero tenemos que ver si es viable o
no así que intentemos calcular su
primera derivada la derivada de 2x es 2
y la derivada de la integral de 0 x df
de tdt por el teorema fundamental
cálculo es efe de x y se dan cuenta que
hay algo muy importante que no está
diciendo esto la derivada de g de x está
definida para cualquier punto por qué
pues porque 2 está definido y fx está
definido para cualquier punto ojo fx no
es derivable en todos los puntos tiene
picos sin embargo fx si está definido
para cualquier punto por lo tanto g
prima de x está definido para todos los
puntos entonces la primera derivada de g
existe y más aún estamos dándonos cuenta
que los puntos críticos los vamos a
obtener haciendo la primera derivada de
g igual a 0 entonces
2 fx es igual a 0 cuando lo voy a
escribir mejor en la parte de arriba 2
más
fx tiene que ser igual a 0 y de aquí yo
tengo que fx tiene que ser igual a menos
2 y entonces la pregunta va a ser para
que valores de x f x es igual a menos 2
si obtenemos los valores de x entonces
la primera derivada de que va a ser
igual a 0 y sería en un punto crítico a
ver entonces
fx es igual a menos 2 voy a hacer una
línea por aquí que me diga que fx es
igual a menos 2 y dense cuenta si yo
empiezo por aquí esto no vale menos 2
esto no vale menos 2 3 no vale menos 2
esto no vale menos el único punto donde
vale menos 2 es este que está sobre una
línea recta y si nos acercamos es como
2.5 o algo no no sé lo que sí podemos
hacer es calcular este valor dada la
recta que tenemos en nuestra gráfica de
fx entonces eso es lo que vamos a hacer
para obtener la ecuación de la recta que
está en fx voy a necesitar primero una
pendiente recuerden que la pendiente es
cambio de y entre cambio de x entonces
quien es el cambio de x
x es de 0 a 3 o sea 3 unidades y el
cambio en que son 6 unidades de tres a
menos tres pero negativas porque la
recta va hacia abajo y bueno la
pendiente es cambio en y entre cambio en
x es lo que desciende entre lo que
avanza y esto va a ser pues menos 6
entre 3 que es menos 2 ya tengo aquí la
pendiente entonces la recta va a tener
la ecuación y es igual a menos dos más
donde corta en el eje de las diez y
corta en el eje leyes en el punto tres
entonces va a ser más tres y entonces ya
tenemos la ecuación de la recta y es
igual a menos 2 x 3
pero para que queríamos esta recta a
pues porque esta recta va a pasar tarde
o temprano por el valor de fx igual a
menos 2 entonces si nosotros igualamos
esta recta a menos 2
vamos a obtener así el valor de x tal
que fx sea igual a menos 2 y ese valor
de x va a ser aquel que haga mi prima
igual a cero entonces metros 2 x 3 es
igual a menos 2 y recuerden que estamos
haciendo
igualdad porque nuestro intervalo de
menos 4 a 3 el único punto en donde fx
es igual a menos 2 es en esta línea
recta por lo tanto menos 2 x 3 es igual
a menos 2 y vamos a seguirlo acá abajo
para resolver esta igualdad si yo el
resto de los dos lados menos 3 obtengo
que menos 2 x es igual a menos 5 y si yo
divido los dos lados entre menos 2
obtengo que x es igual a menos 50 menos
2 o dicho de otra manera x es igual a 5
medios que por cierto era el valor que
saque al tanteo pero bueno este valor de
5 medios lo que hace es que he primate x
sea igual a 0 es decir este es un valor
crítico por lo tanto lo que yo tengo que
calcular es g de cinco medios y ver si
es más grande que g de tres ahora te voy
a comprar es que de tres con que de
cinco medios para ver quién es más
grande y así obtener el máximo absoluto
entonces que de cinco medios quienes
ambos por definición deje es dos por
cinco medios más la integral de cero a
cinco medios
y bueno
2 x 5 medios es muy fácil este 2 con
este 2 se cancela y solamente me queda 5
entonces esto es igual a 5 más la
integral de 0 5 medios df de tdt pero ya
tenemos la función de 0 a 5 medios era
la recta entonces va a ser mucho más
fácil en lugar de poner efe de poner la
recta que ya teníamos y así integrar con
respecto a esta recta entonces va a ser
lo mismo que la integral de 0 a 5 medios
de menos 2 x 3 dt y esto quien es pues
esto es igual a vamos a hacer una línea
para acá a 5 más y voy a poner aquí en
paréntesis quien es la integral de esto
pues esto es la integral de la integral
de menos 2 x es menos 2 x cuadrada entre
2 o sea dicho de otra manera es menos x
cuadrada más la integral de 3 es pues 3x
entonces más 3 x
y esto evaluado en cinco medios y cero
bien pues vamos a hacer la evaluación
esto es igualdad 5 +
esto de aquí va a ser primero lo voy a
evaluar en cinco medios voy a obtener
menos cinco medios al cuadrado que es
menos veinticinco cuartos entonces menos
veinticinco cuartos más tres por cinco
medios que son quince medios ya esto le
tengo que quitar el valor en cero pero
en cero pues no hay nada entonces no hay
que quitarle nada bien y pues vamos a
hacer la operación que está aquí para
esto es sacar el mínimo común múltiplo
entre 14 y 2 que es 4 y entonces me
queda que 5 es lo mismo que 20 cuartos
entonces lo voy a escribir como 20
cuartos
más bien menos a 25 cuartos
- más 15 medios que es lo mismo que 30
cuartos y bien en cuanto es esto pues
2030 son 50 cuartos menos 25 es 25
cuartos entonces esto es igual a 25
cuartos o dicho de otra manera esto es
lo mismo que 6 enteros un cuarto y ya
obtuve el valor paraje de 5 medios y
ahora sí que podemos concluir porque
seis enteros un cuarto es mucho más
grande que el valor de seis y que
también es mucho más grande que el valor
de menos ocho menos dos pi por lo tanto
el valor de x queda un máximo absoluto
en la función g en el intervalo menos 4
menor o igual que x menor o igual que 3
es la equis igual a cinco medios x igual
a cinco medios